hello welcome to three scary games I
have a quarter here if I flip it and it
lands on heads you get a jump scare if
it's tails you get to just go into the
first game and there's no jump scare for
you so you don't need to worry about it
oh I'm gonna flip this and it's gonna be
completely Fair there's a heads and a
Tails it's not focused but you can trust
me it's a normal quarter okay make sense
to everybody coin heads Tails okay here
we go three two one oh
[Music]
hi SpongeBob SpongeBob SpongeBob
SpongeBob SpongeBob SpongeBob SpongeBob
SquarePants we're not unfamiliar with
SpongeBob horror games excuse me
this just so happens to be another one
[Music]
oh
all right I guess that's the most normal
thing that's gonna happen it was a
normal day in underwear zip city what
you were hungry and wanted a human Patty
so you decided to go to the crunchy cons
restaurant
well this makes perfect sense anyone
that doesn't understand doesn't
belong here
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
ah
okay anyway hi who are you wow proceed
to interact do I want to why do you have
such a tidy mouth what is hanging down
below you what's in between your legs I
shouldn't ask that that's rude welcome
to crunchy cons what can I give you
oh I don't know wow this one I'd like a
human Patty please kind of seed I'll
tell you when it's ready
all right
oh I forgot about you hey how you doing
what yo you okay buddy
[Music]
oh this guy went to sleep on ketchup
I'm not even gonna read the end of that
sentence because it's just too stupid
I'm not that stupid can I leave now
wait sir you have a sit your Burger's
almost done
uh-huh
is my human Patty ready it's almost done
but we ran out of Patty so it might take
longer is there any way to speed it up
you can go to the warehouse and get some
that shouldn't be my job be careful it's
dark down there whatever you do do not
go to the room at the end of the
corridor
okay I'm gonna listen to what you said
[Music]
no okay
okay goodbye I'm gonna go down here now
oh great this is fantastic oh this is
just exactly what I was hoping for in
the Darkness
is this a room at the end of the
corridor I remember you saying something
about the room at the end of the
corridor this is the end of the corridor
in this room
all right I'm going okay well there all
right
um
a brain please expunge anything you just
saw
great can't wait to get whatever the
hell I'm seeing here
oh
but this isn't the end of the corridor
is it well well well
that's definitely ketchup it's probably
the room that they put their ketchups
inside
I'm super smart I hello I'm ooh
you know
he warned me
scombardio Squilliam tennis balls warned
me that that would happen and it did so
I can only be upset at myself so
Patty's now
who's coming from oh what ah glad
all right why was this so difficult
why was this a problem for you
why could nobody have gotten this
why was nobody able to do this for me
well a job well done
glad that didn't go horribly wrong
[Music]
[Music]
would you like a paddy
okay oh
hey wait a minute
was there ketchup someone should clean
this up I guess it's gonna be me because
I seem to have to do everything around
here hey I got the food that you were
supposed to make for me but I got it he
actually managed to get a Patty from the
cursive Warehouse good job
the fourth from the last word you said
I'll go inside the kitchen and put it on
the grill
[Music]
he said that it was almost ready you
said that you said that it was almost
ready you made the statement that it was
in fact almost ready
okay
all right great flopper on the grill
Wham
peasy is this what I'm supposed to do is
there anything else I'm supposed to do
am I supposed to let it burn oh
probably normal
I have to take a bread while it's frying
oh
[Music]
uh do I go home now
[Music]
hi
hello
hello
sit down and enjoy your human Patty all
right I'm fine whatever
[Music]
I don't really blame myself that'll be
wow
87.99
why is it so expensive it must be his
mistake 98 90
of 35. so you're saying you don't have
the money
okay you don't need a yell
oh hey how's it going buddy
look I can't help but feel that might
have been a little bit unnecessary
oh my God it's Shrek I'm a huge fan
I'm trying to steal the secret formula
but I failed and Mr Crab put me in this
cage how'd you get stuck in here did you
try to steal the secret formula
no it's too expensive I didn't have
enough money I know Mr Crab is an
[ __ ] I'll try to save you from this
cage don't really try Mr Krabs locked
the cage and Swallowed the Key but good
luck anyway why would I help you you
you are the most disturbing person in
this place
and there was a starfish smacking his
face into the door
box with two balls they don't seem
useful
a few small boxes not useful
okay Skeleton Key
oh
ah I see now okay well there's three
fish there's one starfish right there oh
two starfish actually there's four boxes
and then there's two balls okay so t t
why why
are you
you I I
did that work
oh wait there would be five because
there would be another box inside of
them it would be five
you
curse
where did that click come from
I'm free
I'm free I'm gonna check the rim at the
end of the hall
I have to save the green guy first why
why would I have why why why would I
have to do that why would I have to do
that why would anybody want to do that
oh a useful tool
all right
I'm Gonna Save You Shrek
oh wow
thank you for saving me let's go find a
way out of this place
I don't know why what was the game the
man from the window I just thought of
the
freaking mama bunny I don't know why I
don't know why I just got Mama bunny on
my mind
what you're not expecting out of a
character all right let's go pal let's
go we got a good place to be
I'll have to put the tool
I have to put the
I have to put the tool back apparently
because I'm very polite I wouldn't want
to have that with me no way
freak
finally
all right let's get out of here
freedom freedom free
player plankton
why he no follow
oh
you're no photo am I not supposed to be
here
am I supposed to be somewhere else where
exactly am I supposed to be
okay
oh hi
uh right oh
[Music]
oh
not Rick Roll
[Music]
four five
five
oh
five oh
five oh
508
509
5089 is that what I need should I just
go now
okay I guess that's stuck okay 5089
glad I went through that 5089 got it hey
bud how you doing good to see you 508 9.
well so far this has been an adventure
um
five oh eight nine
whoa what good is that gonna do me it
tasted like my grandma's toenail
s
[Music]
oh
[Music]
well I probably you know what maybe
maybe what if I didn't what if I didn't
what if I didn't run what if I'm not a
coward what if I'm not gonna run away
what if I'm gonna stand right here what
if I'm gonna make my stand huh what if I
want to go toe-to-toe with whatever's
gonna come through that door what if I
want them to give me what if I want them
to kill me what if I want them to try
all right anyway whatever
you there yet
[Music]
I thought I thought something would be
like chasing me or something
[Music]
oh
fine whatever I thought it was gonna
come from behind me and little did I
know that you were just gonna be not
doing anything
fine whatever
[Music]
[Music]
well it seems to be pretty far away I'm
very good
[Music]
okay I'm starting to get lost out if I
have to start backtracking I'm gonna be
in big trouble okay grec is what ah
I don't know what that means
[Music]
greck is
uh
is there gonna be an answer on the wall
somewhere around here am I just gonna be
running around forever
whoa oh oh oh
well I
well I
foreign
[Music]
am I not sure that I wanna yeah I'm not
sure
so you are not sure that you are sure
yes
by no you mean no
okay chill let me ask you one question
did you like this game I love it so much
oh I see wow what an incredible
well copyright is your content is
removed I don't think it was good stuff
great stuff actually
I think this is a game that everybody
can relate to because most everybody has
been to an eye doctor and in that office
in the dark muggy back room of that
office you're sat in front of a machine
you're told to look press your face up
against the machine you've never seen
before you look in a hole and
for most people out there you see a
House at the End of the Road a rumor has
it
that some people
see a hot air balloon
let me tell you
that hot air balloon doesn't exist
it's a test
and if you saw the hot air balloon you
failed
okay anyway
oh wow it really is just like my I have
perfect eye vision now
my eyes are super I don't need to do
that anymore but yes hello
what do I do this is for the rare people
that see a hot air balloon instead of a
instead of a house hold shift to run
actually I want a show of hands because
I know for a fact it's the majority of
people see a house I want to know who of
you have seen a hot air balloon when you
look in the machine uh because it's it's
just like interesting because it's like
a right-handed left-handed thing I know
that majority of people are right-handed
and like majority people see a house I
personally did not see a hot air balloon
I just want to know if you guys saw a
hot air balloon
hello
hello
hello is it getting closer is it part of
the sky box or is this
I think it's getting closer
I'm pretty sure anyway someday it'll be
here
eventually
it's gonna turn into a house any minute
for me
hello
that's an eyeball that's an asset
eyeball
I'm not gonna read into that
nothing weird about that perfectly
ordinary that that's fine that is 100 a
okay
totally fine it's a lie I know that I
know it's an optical illusion but I'm
going towards it anyway
guys I don't feel so good
okay
so uh
so what about this
huh
I think it might be a lie guys
no
no
oh God no
oh no
oh no
is that like the fight is that what you
guys see if you see a balloon in the
dust
oh
oh
[Music]
I love a good nap at the optometrists
oh yawn
y I can't move well
looks like I'm trapped here
okay
ah good game seriously let me know in
the comments who saw an air balloon who
saw a house I want to get a pole of
who's doomed in my own
in the end of the day
moving on
welcome to SpongeBob killer pants if
you're wondering if you've seen this
game before just because it's a
SpongeBob horror game no you haven't
it's another SpongeBob horror game this
one SpongeBob killer pants
clearly it was Friday the 23rd of
September you worked as a cleaner at the
Krusty Krab
you were used to the job by now it was
normal as normal as a job at the Krusty
Krab could possibly be until that night
when it when it feel normal
whatever that means you heard noises
that of which you had never experienced
before
were you going crazy or was there
something truly evil lurking inside
was there where am I hello
oh I don't think that they were that
close in their homes I'm not caught up
on the SpongeBob lore but uh that seems
a little
a little proximal also amazing that we
can see the stars this deep below the
ocean
oh
[Music]
start shift
oh my God it's dark in here
pretty faithful Recreation
I feel like I was just here a little bit
ago oh the Places I've traveled all the
things I've seen
everything's fine
you think this element could have done
this before it closed
usually they do this before close
it about here then
[Music]
I'm getting paranoid again
next thing I know someone's gonna come
jumping out at me
probably
okay wait
what was that what am I looking at what
am I looking at oh another building
okay take trash out to the dumpster
behind the building
okay do I have the trash in my I do
okay
[Music]
it's weirdly empty in Bikini Bottom I
don't know if people live in those
buildings or what
creep
do I really need to investigate
is that really what I need to do at this
moment yeah the Chum Bucket was on it
now that they're done married doesn't
matter it does not matter
doesn't matter
well that door is sparkly so I'm
assuming that's where I go
oh
another basement in the bottom
of the Krusty Krab houses
shirt
oh [ __ ] oh my God
[Applause]
what I got my zoom lens back and I just
keep
Menace okay well that's bad
oh
that's probably not good
I'm leaving my body now I'm descending
into the Ethereal plane oh great
[Music]
oh
well
I'm dead I don't know if I had any other
way to go but
I could have done about that differently
but uh hey I'm dead and you're dead too
and that it was another fantastic
SpongeBob horror experience we can all
agree we can all agree
[Music]
all right thank you so much for three
scary games watching
all the games are listed in the
description below along with more scary
games that I've played I'm gonna flip
this coin again remember this if it goes
heads you have to subscribe if it goes
tails you don't all right fair enough
well you can use some kind of trick I'm
gonna trick you twice with the same
thing no it's a fair deal fair play you
got to the end which means you enjoyed
the content but it doesn't mean that you
have to do what you need to do whatever
YouTuber asks you to do it's all down to
the coin it's all about a chance
okay
good luck
[Music]